[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala con nosotros en el
estudio Mara bienvenida iniciamos una
nueva semana informativa así de Raúl
buenos días Vamos a nosotros comenzar
hablando de una vacuna contra el dengue
que ha recibido la luz verde en Europa
si es una noticia que llegó este fin de
semana y que de hecho ya se esperaba Ya
teníamos buenos resultados de esta
vacuna es la segunda que existe contra
el dengue y se parece con la Pues la
primera vacuna que existía en algunos
aspectos en otros difiere vamos a
repasarlo no la primera se aprobó hace
años desde la farmacéutica casanofi con
el Instituto pasteur mientras que la
otra es de la farmacéutica takeda
japonesa ambas son de virus atenuado Qué
significa eso pues que se usa un virus
vivo del dengue pero que se debilita
hasta el punto que no puede crear una
infección pero si despertar una
respuesta inmune además son
tetravalentes eso significa que
funcionan contra los cuatro serotipos
del virus del dengue que existen y que
pueden infectar a las personas pero la
gran diferencia es que la vacuna de
Sanofi se que poner a personas que ya
habían tenido hubieran tenido al menos
una infección previa porque se descubrió
en el 2017 que en las personas que no
tenían anticuerpos previos contra el
dengue la vacuna aumentaba el riesgo de
una infección posterior con dengue grave
entonces por ejemplo muchas pues entre
regulatorios como en Estados Unidos la
recomendaban solo entre los nueve y los
16 años también porque a partir de
Entonces no había buenos datos sobre su
eficacia en cambio en este caso pues a
pesar de que no tengamos todavía pues la
los datos que surgen de una aplicación a
gran escala de una vacuna parece que no
parece comportar este riesgo algo que
podría abrir las puertas de una
vacunación o más más amplia mar y
digamos hablemos ahora de las
implicaciones que pueda tener esta nueva
vacuna en la que estamos hablando Pues a
ver primero el dengue es una de las
enfermedades que más se ha expandido en
los últimos años y que más se prevé que
se expanda en el futuro no a raíz sobre
todo de que cada vez hay más vectores de
este mosquito que transmite la
enfermedad por ejemplo por factores como
el cambio
automático en general la infección
provoca un cuadro leve Pero puede
evolucionar hasta complicaciones bien
América Latina Perdón en todo el
continente americano en 2019 hubo 25.000
casos graves además es una enfermedad
sin tratamientos no existen tratamientos
específicos contra el dengue Entonces
esta vacuna de taquera primero podría
obviamente ayudar a vacunar ampliamente
más la población pero también hacer algo
muy interesante y es que Los viajeros de
zonas donde no existe el dengue que
viajen a zonas donde esta enfermedad es
endémica se pueden vacunar no podían
hacerlo con la desanopy porque no tenían
infección previa y así además de
proteger Pues a estos viajeros también
se podría prevenir que las personas
traigan el dengue de regreso a países
donde esta enfermedad no es endémica y
así hacer una especie de Barrera a esta
expansión constante de la enfermedad que
estamos viendo en los últimos años
cambiamos ahora información bar mar nos
vamos a uganda para actualizar toda la
información sobre el borde de Hola que
afecte ese país sí Raúl y es que este
fin de semana las autoridades tuvieron
que declarar una cuarentena en distritos
donde se está dando este brote
escuchémoslo
into los desplazamientos al interior y
exterior de los distritos de movendey de
casanda están prohibidos
tenemos ahora un total de 58 casos
confirmados y 19 muertes
58 casos confirmados 19 muertes estos
sin contar los casos sospechosos o que
no se han podido confirmar clínicamente
no pero hay alguna buena noticia Y es
que el serum institute de India que es
el mayor manufacturador de
vacunas del mundo dio un anuncio
recordemos que este brote lo está dando
de ébola la variante de Sudán la cepa de
Sudán que no tiene pues tratamientos ni
vacunas aprobados para combatirlos no y
en cambio si existe una vacuna
desarrollada En fase clínica 1 por la
universidad de Oxford y astracénica pero
digamos está de nuevo en fases muy
iniciales no sin embargo ser un institut
se pues se propuso para para producir
entre 20.000 y 30.000 dosis poder
llevarlas gratuitamente a este país a
uganda y ayudar tanto a combatir el
brote como también a recabar cifras y
datos de cómo está funcionando
verdaderamente esta vacuna para combatir
pues la enfermedad no Y además también
hubo críticas como vemos aquí en una
cita de los investigadores del de la
Universidad de Oxford que están
desarrollando esta vacuna Porque dijeron
que si hubiera habido más inversión
previa hubiéramos hubiéramos tenido Ya
esta vacuna disponible y no haría falta
estar como a las carreras o haciendo
estas cosas como a último minuto Exacto
vamos ahora a terminar con una donación
que hizo la fundación Gates en la lucha
contra la poliomar sí esto lo hicieron
en el marco de la Cumbre mundial por la
salud que se está desarrollando a lo
largo de toda esta semana en Alemania la
fundación Gates ya es donante habitual
en la lucha contra el polio de hecho es
prácticamente el único financiador del
programa de la OMS de la erradicación de
la polio algo que despierta tanto
alabanzas como críticas en algunos
sectores en este caso donaron 1.200
millones de dólares especialmente
enfocados en Pakistán y en Afganistán
los dos países donde el apoyo es
endémica y aquí en el comunicado vemos
no como dicen eso que los últimos pasos
a estas radicación son los más difíciles
Por qué Porque además últimamente las
cosas se han puesto todavía más
difíciles en este espacio lo hemos dicho
ya varias veces las tasas de vacunación
en todo el mundo y eso también ha hecho
que por ejemplo surjan algunos pequeños
brotes en países donde todavía no había
donde pues no se había registrado
durante muchos años ya estamos hablando
de Estados Unidos Reino Unido pero
también de algunos países africanos como
malawi no y es que además Pues el reto
de la radicación del apoyo no es hacer
que desaparezca solo de los países
endémicos sino que generación tras
generación todos los niños de los países
donde el apoyo ya no circula también se
vacuna para evitar precisamente estos
brotes que hacen que la tarea sea tan
difícil a medida que pasa el tiempo mar
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de salud mañana Por
supuesto con mucho más mañana y pasa